next up you brought us an important
story from inside edition deborah yeah
we did and this is something that really
got people crazed when we did this story
there's a new way for naughty people to
track you a lot of stalkers out there
using a very common technology for
devious purposes and it's an air tag but
this is this is all it is it's a tiny
little device apple started making it
last spring and they're used to track
everything from your wallet your
pocketbook here i'll hold it still sorry
you can put it on your luggage right
yeah i didn't put them on my dogs that's
a smart idea yeah well lucy got out in
the woods the other day right and so you
were able to find her
yeah with the with the air trackers no i
was before the air tracker oh so i went
and got the air tracker because i
thought i don't want this to happen okay
but how would you like it if somebody
took this air tracker and stuck it into
your pocket right here
i would not like you you would not like
that at all um unfortunately people are
using this technology to do just that to
follow people to stalk them and we did a
story where this poor girl as you see on
camera here is trying to find the air
tag she knows it's in there she finally
found it in the inside of her door kind
of behind the handle and the only way
she knew that it was there it popped up
on her phone there's an air tag
somewhere but it's really hard to find
really so does this um
memo on your phone come up if you're not
paired with it is it a warning how does
it function deborah so it comes up on
your phone and it says that an unknown
accessory has been detected it has been
moving with you for a while the owner
can see the location so the owner can go
on his phone he will see essentially
like the map that tells you how to get
from point a to point b it's a map of
where you have been with this air tag on
your person or in your car now apple's
been very clear about this they condemn
this kind of misuse and they say to stay
safe you will always get an alert on
your phone if you're anywhere near an
unknown air tag and if you've got an
android device you can download the
track detector that apple's put out
there it'll give you the same kind of
alert well you know there's so many good
things we get with technology but this
is one of those scary things and it's
freaking out drew barrymore right now i
can see on your face well i'm very glad
to know about it i have to say before
you brought this story to our attention
i did not know about really and now i
feel very empowered
to understand what is happening so thank
you deborah seriously deborah and now we
can all benefit from not being like oh
that's nothing now we know what to look
for so thank you you're welcome
ross you have a story yeah well next up
this is a change of topics we're going
to talk about brazilian butt lifts
for those of you who don't know what
that is the bbl is one of the most
popular cosmetic procedures on the
planet there were at least 40 000
performed last year alone but apparently
it there's a black market that's
capitalizing on this demand and it can
be a huge health hazard it can even be
deadly deborah what do you know about
this this is another one of these
stories that we've done that's really
scary um if you say there's 40 000 that
were done last year the death rate is
one in three thousand now with normal
cosmetic surgery it's one in fifty
thousand so it's a lot more risky so
from your 40 000 that's like
statistically 13 women died from having
a butt lift done wow and
you're catching flies in there because i
can tell you're shocked we actually went
to one of these places that we found
advertising on instagram we went
undercover just to show exactly how
these operators work this was an
unlicensed person who was advertising
but injections on instagram doing them
they didn't even know what was inside
the needle so some of these places um
they have chemicals like fix a flat
yes when your tire goes flat cement
liquid you know that stuff that like
fills in the cracks experts say do the
research
if they don't know what's in the needle
then you certainly don't want to have
anything done no
make sure you go to a board-certified
medical professional make sure you
understand the risk
and maybe just embrace your backside and
love what the lord gave you well yeah
so scary
i mean hello fix a flat is for tires
it's not to fix your flat butt
this is so crazy i i but i just have to
say i love
the drew crime or i should say inside
edition x drew crime i love it i love
doing this with you let's do it more
these are please yes
i love it here deborah i love you so
much deborah norville catcher on inside
edition every weekday
let's please do this more absolutely
inside edition x through crime
[Music]
you